welcome the fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith mark barnard Hey look at this my
old school yeah your candy Wow slipping
right into your ear canal doing it doing
it ear [ __ ] we're we're doing it with
no with our eyes closed this group
actually you're living with your eyes
closed this week
no visual component but [ __ ] this all
ship began in front of a microphone and
I was as I was reminded by Bobby
Moynihan on this weekend I do like
podcast that was off as an old school I
watched the very first Harriet live of
us era live man my whole life and that's
what I originally wanted to do before
even before films is I'm gonna be a
writer for Senate line this weekend on
Sara lab they did celebrity jeopardy
nice and is when the sketch began it's a
very familiar Jersey on the stage and I
was like now I call you I did they just
knock it up they's made it they I saw
the Reebok label on it on the sleeves
they grabbed a you know [ __ ] Reebok
memmingen Jersey and then just modified
at the front hood regardless it was
pretty awesome um and like I got off
light it wasn't like you know [ __ ]
stabbing me in the heart and in the eye
a thousand times where I was like I used
to like no it was awesome
Woody Allen took it harder holy good oh
yeah so steve-o playa
so Jennifer Lawrence actually took it
out of it than I did I'm just a normal
girl an excellent time I was really fun
he's like how annoyingly relatable you
are that was a pretty damn dope and uh
you know if you wait long enough kids
you get everything you've ever wanted
always much beyond saying life well I
got it was okay so I'm up in Vancouver
slam Coover hmm making flash we shot a
piece of enough of the art my episode
last Monday because we were losing to
the actors for our shoot week so it was
like well let's grab it while we can
they were like how do you feel about
like
acting early I'm like well I'm here I
get up at 5:00 and I directly every day
so we we directed a little bit
last Monday which was nice a nice way to
kind of like break the ice and see how
everybody works and stuff and you know I
was really concerned that I would not be
able to do the job you know everybody
[ __ ] hates my guts like you can't do
the job anyway but in the pair in the
world where I can do the job that's why
they gave it to me um I was nervous that
I would be there and not have an opinion
mmm like essentially they do a take and
I just be like it's so [ __ ] good such
a super lady and then just and they just
move on
but I actually like had an opinion after
each take like and not like here's my
opinion were just enough to be like all
right let's do we could do minor
correction and do this and stuff so that
was a relief
Jessie Martin I love you that's my
opinion yes he comes like here's my
direction oh my god
crushing I saw him I sat down with a
cast did read through the script and
they like brought it man I thought we
were literally gonna read through it but
they acted it out was pretty awesome
it looks like it's gonna be a good time
and they're very well prepared up there
we have like a zillion meetings and
stuff I there's some things in TV I've
never done before like a tone meeting
that's where they go through the script
and scene-by-scene tell you what the
tone is because this is a writer's
medium like if anybody's you know like
[ __ ] I wanna I want to be in charge but
I'm a writer and the only way to do that
is by writing and directing indie films
that's what I thought had I known that
in TV the writers game I would have went
the [ __ ] into TV like my god that's
that's who controls television is the
writers yeah they call them different
names though that's all it's like here's
an EP right here's your showrunner yeah
a producer co-executive but is your blah
blah blah blah blah all writers yeah
right it's a right as the best-kept
secret in the world
that's where writers go to [ __ ] die
become gods I know like you don't even
like the lowest level writer when
there's on set coming their episode they
kind of call the shots and it's bigger
than the highest level direction
I'll tell you that so um yeah the
writers [ __ ] king in that meeting so
you go through the script we do a lot of
[ __ ] via Skype I wonder what they used
to do back I guess just [ __ ] him
they wouldn't even think oh my god like
he would only what they do in lost in
that lot but since the you know the
production - or the writing and the
executive producers and I don't know
what you would call creative because
it's creative them you're the entire
staff that the writing staff writing
staff is down south and here in Los
Angeles and everyone else is up north so
they Skype and have meetings and stuff
so we had this one meeting a tone
meeting where they go over one of the
helping brothers who runs that show went
through the script like scene by scene
to be like you know okay so in this
scene like they're feeling good about
things like literally the tone meeting
is like if you're tone deaf let me
explain what is such a cheery in every
way now sherry but apparently it's
necessary because some cat and this will
blew my mind I mean I guess it shouldn't
blow my mind but some people are like
what's this show about I've never seen
it like they're working directors that
just like do ten of these a year and
they don't all watch the shows that they
work on they can't I guess not so I you
know I must happen to be a fan who just
happens to have enough like you know
credit credibility or bona fides behind
me to direct the episode but they're
like you're a rare beast dude like you
come in like we were going around I made
a joke about like the we were they were
like we're doing a scout to like there's
the exterior of jitters CC jitters and I
was like well but and then JP was like
well let's stop and get coffee I was
like let's get coffee at [ __ ] jitters
man I'll get a flash and my man in
locations was just like it's nice to
have somebody on the show that watches
the show like best deep cuts no on the
[ __ ] name of coffee
so it's it's like I guess it's not I
just assumed everyone's like me but not
necessarily not like like I hate the
show but I'll direct it but I thought
every like you wouldn't go near the flat
unless you were remotely interested in
the flash and same for like I wouldn't
go near Merrick was that [ __ ] house
of cards my Netflix well made show but
like I would never like it's in fact if
they called me I'd be intimidated be
like oh god no your show is very good
there's no room for error there you get
had neither people died if the show was
okay yeah and they watch it a lot on
that Netflix so but flash like I felt
like I just thought I assumed director
just leaned toward the [ __ ] they like
but some some don't yes I'm just like
done yeah bombing in I'm here for 10
days bombing out what's next crazy there
a magnum p.i I can shoot know if there
was like we wouldn't be here in fact
there's so much production up there dude
on the vancouver film studio stages not
just flashes there but arrows there and
legends there is room so you know it's
they all have their own worlds and sets
obviously but they cross a little bit
like some of the legends folks were
shooting on some flash things like last
week yeah and some flash episode of no
arrow was shooting on it seems like they
they hey let's try to go to fly minor
thank you for the gut but cisco make me
a suit there's that's the thing they
could always do that kind of mmm
like crossover thing that's been the
other fun thing about being on the show
dude is i know it happens off the season
except for the last episode but i know
the whole storyline I have a preview a
little bit of next season new rule um I
get me obvious I think every way it's
not my information to give it oh my god
I was sitting there go no now yeah a
button a great way yeah like yes it was
the no that was yes
the only time admittedly this is what a
geek is just like oh do it to me harder
what who yeah that's yeah it's like when
they yeah there's a good [ __ ] coming
excellent it's very cool um so yeah man
it's been like real like I you know my
biggest fear going up there obviously
was like I'm gonna suck at this but you
can't you can suck at it but that
machine is so well-oiled
that you wouldn't suck at it you'd have
to [ __ ] go well out of your way to
suck at it just look at it and you know
honestly they don't even need a director
like if I got shot in the head on my way
just about to walk on set and the Winter
Soldier took me out across the [ __ ]
alley or whatever they would they could
date you know they might be a little sad
cos we've spent a week to get like oh I
seem like a good guy but they could go
on shooting what's already on one right
okay let's go my god what a waste the
fragility of human life here we go
everybody rolls out quite on set when I
move that body to the shop it's been
wonderful to watch what an education but
all those people up there like they all
like the show that's the nice thing
everyone working on the show likes the
show they're not like whatever dude it's
about a guy from America that runs fast
but not at all all of them are like
dialed in give a [ __ ] about the stories
and stuff like that throw storytellers
so that's that you you know you sit
there watching show you why why do I
connect with this show more than other
shows why is this night marked different
than all of them maybe that's going a
bit too Tuesday's to the face but it's
more about like why like why why do I
connect with this on every level why
does it work so well there's just my
estimation but I think the shows that
really [ __ ] punch through and make
you go like I'll [ __ ] you get the
general impression everybody wants to be
there yeah saying that's what this is
like you don't have anybody going like
[ __ ] like seriously boy runnin show come
on like everybody [ __ ] loves it
believes in it and they all like doing
they know they're making something cool
I think that translates yeah I mean like
you look at stuff that should not work
on the surface of it like this show
should not work yeah like Battlestar
should not have worked
you're absolutely everybody believes
like everybody believes in that mission
and everybody's committed to executing
at the highest level they can and once
again the writer is king in that medium
that show was about idea
more so than like you know
monster-of-the-week space of the week
[ __ ] problem of the week it was you
know that was a writer show god it's so
wait why did I [ __ ] skip television
fart that's what I'm waking up to this
week
I'm liking I [ __ ] thought I found an
easy path with indie film when I do
whatever I want Malibu [ __ ] I
couldn't whatever I wanted as a writer
and I would have been a lot wealthier oh
my god like that's where writers go to
become richest gracious because once you
got a show on the air for like I know
two seasons yeah you're it's nuts you're
gold they back trucks of money up to
your house and once your Berlanti with
like six shows on the air he probably
owns a country so what is he's shopping
for islands resolved a island nation
ivory
where's like we could shoot the next
show here in the next show is Batman on
is there gonna give him one sooner or
later he's just like how about that
Hawaii could we get that Hawaii like
well I don't know it's Gotham 500 I like
well I just got them have to be as yet
all can't be on a beautiful island um
yeah man that's true like the Norman
Lear's of this world
greg berlanti 'he's the [ __ ] John
Wells is the John Wells is the John
Wells is so wealthy from television he
did er he financed his own like movies
yeah like he's not like me where I'm
like brother could just bear a dime if
he's like [ __ ] it I'll make it get a
movie for twenty five million bucks or
something done that's television dude
television is the ability to make a
movie there's spare time um yeah it's
real [ __ ] it's it's pretty fascinating
what an education it's been but but uh
fun and and uh but now the real work on
begins
yeah but again like like the DP Kim dude
like that's he's like I'm here all week
like I'm here every day like you get to
come and go but like I'm gonna make sure
the show looks phenomenal because like
yeah that's what I do
yeah like I've been I've been stared at
these people furred T him mom she's
forgotten ways to shoot angley's
forgotten angles to shoot these people
Fermi shot them so much and so and he
also knows how to play the every room
cuz you know sooner or later there's an
end to every set but he can like that
place looks big I was on the floor where
they you know the season finale was
where he was running through the
Arkan tunnel where Wells was in his
prison cell and shilling Minh and it's
crazy like you look out it was when
Tyler the production designer pointed
out I'm like holy [ __ ] this is this room
it's tall as [ __ ] it's giant set and for
an episode for the episode prior to mine
and for my episode they had to build a
contraption hmm that's at play and it's
a gigantic machine and I've deflect I've
been around movies 22 years I defy
anyone tell me this is not cinematic
like level one no set building like it
looks like you could shoot Batman V
Superman on this [ __ ]
but they're shooting flash but there's
no difference anymore you know what I'm
saying like all these shows treat these
show their material so like
cinematically that there is no you when
we were kids used to be like those TV
and there's movies like you know you
could tell the difference between all
the President's Men and the Six Million
Dollar Man but this is a million dollars
but now it's like you can show the flash
on a big screen like if you just shot it
[ __ ] a little more widescreen or
whatever you don't have to do that most
TVs are kind of like their HD exactly so
I mean you could it's it's I mean maybe
it's like ridiculous to say are we done
at this point but like they're crushing
it in TV land so I mean I know this
because I watched way more TV than go to
the movies these days and the
consistency and the speed with which
they could do it dude like we've been
waiting three years for Batman V
Superman since the moment they announced
it now we're finally going to see it
soon somebody handed like Tyler the
Broxton designer [ __ ] script two
weeks ago and said we need you know this
giant [ __ ] machine and he two weeks
later it's exists and they're shooting
it yeah and then maybe a month or two
later we're gonna watch it like noon
they satisfied dreams and demands so
fast like even from jump even from the
we have a pilot script let's go shoot
this pilot and then let's put it on the
air that is an insanely fast turnaround
anyway if the pilot gets greenlit in
January they start shooting it in March
and it's picked up for series or not in
May and they gotta build a whole world
I'm gonna build a world in two months
that's got to look great for five years
and twenty-two dude it is tough
twenty-two our lungs like you know I
said they're gone like we're working on
Holly weed Holly we'd be like ten
episodes if it gets picked up this you
know [ __ ] that's that's the luxury of
like you know oh we're on cable or we're
going for streaming or whatever [ __ ]
network TV is just like 2023 dude they
do 23 episodes 23 hours almost one full
day of [ __ ] flash programming they're
going to produce over the course of the
year and they do it like in and unlike
you know there's that rule in TV will
rules sevens or someone's like yes seven
great episodes 7 ok episodes and 7 dog
ship so it's because you're moving so
fast they can't all be great I am
flattered actually [ __ ] pull that
average way to [ __ ] up there's no dog
[ __ ] so there's like [ __ ] 12 11 12 13
[ __ ] great and 10 good so either way
you know like so so episode of the flash
it's like that's pretty good it's like
even a so show up so the flash is is
like a half-hearted [ __ ] you're like
oh my god it was in something warm wet
and I came nobody bit and everything was
no complain it's like it was ok pizza
but it was still beats that's true and
there's no such thing as bit well I know
this is true
I had a [ __ ] slice of pizza boy died
maybe it'd be oh my lord bagra and do a
lot of things right but I walked into a
pizza burger slice to be fair piece of
joint I walked into is not should that
be held as indicative of all bank River
pizza but I walked in and I honestly
thought I walked into an aquarium it's
because the gentleman running this piece
of shop had more [ __ ] fish on display
the saddest two aquariums I've ever seen
not like there's some fake [ __ ] weeds
and rocks and like empty dude these fish
just hover hasn't been boring like oh my
god they don't end up on a slice poor
actually praying for it it's like that
would be better than this
kill me now yeah make me that anchovy um
it was kind of [ __ ] nuts and then so
I got a slice of pizza and oh man it was
not like it's hard enough in LA as an
East Coaster to be like at least it
resembles pizza right it's kind of pizza
ish there was no suggestion of a crust
it was just tablet goo yeah I kind of
liked it like almost pita with sauce and
have you met in Italian no cheese yes it
was like somebody explained the concept
of feeds into this guy using all the
wrong way he was like I got it one word
and built a bucket business and then was
so lonely surrounded so [ __ ] fish um
yeah I was not good but other than that
big group not well all right let's jump
off flash all right before I [ __ ] cuz
sooner or later I'm gonna be like you
know what's gonna happen by the way
really oh my god some shits gonna make
me it made me happy hearing about it
seeing it's gonna be like a religious
experience let's dive into some news
shall we mark your ah the biggest news
of the week yeah why we lit the beacons
oh my lord why why I had to rush home
but when you got a direct him like now I
got to talk about this now son come boy
the guys are fine without me
let's see on Tuesday they dropped the
Marvel Captain America civil war trailer
yeah number 2 full trailer and it was
the furthest thing from number 2 no
unless it was number 2 4 straight from
the anus of the Lord Himself and God
number two's unicorns yes with in number
2 in like strawberry sauce that's how
good it was God unicorn put that on a
post this trailer was phenomenal I
wasn't expecting it nobody said it's
coming do it honestly just felt like a
real [ __ ] you the Warner Brothers that's
what it felt like dude like we're here
with less than what is the date we are
now in the 13th so that means we are two
weeks out like yes two weeks out
from less than 12 [ __ ] days right now
12 days from now we will have seen
Batman V Superman and boy oh boy
Marvel couldn't just give it to him can
just be like good enjoy your weaker
victory it's not guys they [ __ ] threw
a trailer out there that makes you go
move over Batman and Superman I can't
see some Piderman under oon how did they
make us excited about the same [ __ ]
we've seen now but a thing we knew was
coming and we knew it was go and it's no
surprise and one could argue is like
puzzling to the mainstream mmm-hmm this
incarnation of spider-man yeah because
it mainstream's used to watching these
movies got big plastic eyes and stuff
like that they showed us a spider-man
that essentially was the Steve Ditko
spider-man from the old spider-man
spider-man that are too bright super
just and his eyes were expressive his
eyes were and we heard photo aperture
going with his as his eyes moved which
was smart leads us to believe Tony Stark
probably built that mask for him
although Peter Parker as a scientist
true but what is the reason for the
nobody they have like spider-man club
like science club with Tony Stark and
Peter Parker and where he's like the
only thing we have in common a science
cuz you're poor and I'm rich but science
you're the other your child of a man
leaping with a supermodel but science
but we saw a fantastic [ __ ] Steve
Ditko look in spider-man just the youth
on the internet were a little puzzled
kid I saw some people reacting like what
the [ __ ] is with his eyes and it's like
dude what's with his eyes that right
there is Marvel going you didn't think
we could possibly show you anything
different with spider-man yeah you were
[ __ ] wrong [ __ ] we did oh my god
with one [ __ ] what 10 second shot
they reclaim the glory of their [ __ ]
flagship character of their masted
character of spider-man that
made me so excited not just for civil
war but for the new spider-man movie
yeah and I haven't said that maybe ever
do serious I mean maybe the first time I
heard about the same Raimi spider-man
though though all that be cool yeah but
now I'm like oh my god [ __ ] that's
fantastic dude that just those eyes
being expressive moving and the dark
black around them and [ __ ] what
they're probably doing if I had to guess
this is the first appearance of
spider-man in the Marvel Universe
you're gonna look like Ditko next time
we see him maybe he looks a little
different maybe he looks like you know
Todd McFarlane's spider-man ooh maybe
after that he looks like you know what
I'm saying so for the salons of it yeah
and rather than just being like let's
make the costume with the raised webbing
and the big eyes like they've done in
the movie after movie maro cats were
like you were done trying to make
spider-man real yeah we don't have to
yeah think about it
he's [ __ ] wet and they're just like
so we're gonna make those eyes move yeah
like there's that we have a universe
with a Hulk and an Asgardian God why
does this dude have to have like
basketball knitting outfit wash barn so
smart man I you that you know what
that's from that's Kevin Feige sitting
forced to watch 20 years of spider-man
movies going if I was in charge and now
he is in charge and so we got here you
go oh my it's fantastic to kind of
[ __ ] amazing world do we live in
where spider-man's
eyes grow and shrink on the mask that's
so [ __ ] dope the one thing that was
weird though was when he spoke mmm like
what okay spider-man looks like looking
at his musculature
he looks like a grown-ass man yeah what
he sounds like he's 12
hey guys oh please batter me it was so
nice to hear kids boys as opposed to
like some 45 year old man hey good yeah
hey I'm in high school I got your shield
mom that was perfect perfect line choice
of
you know hey everybody like whatever it
was just a perfect intro to that
character
the trailer was so good I forgot I
didn't honestly think they would show a
spider-man I thought it would be like
[ __ ] you guys at that point they didn't
need to know we were all going anyway
yeah the trailer looked at me that shot
of the [ __ ] two teams running at each
other almost like the opening of the
Super Friends and Jim [ __ ] Hawkeye
shoots aiming through
Tony's fingers like he lands through the
glove and on his arm so you know he's
gonna like grow a good punishment of
[ __ ] know it well in the face um it
all of it is great like it's just a fun
[ __ ] of this movie looks [ __ ] amazing
and then like it ain't even a cherry on
top
it's like they gave you this amazing
sundae and then just when you're like aw
I'm [ __ ] done they're like here's a
bigger song guys like oh did you like
your fudgie the whale cake here's
another fudgie the whale cake cuz I'm
Tom Carvel Wednesday is Sunday at Carvel
it wasn't Wednesday
all I could swirly rush it right into my
mouth do it oh my lord it was amazing ah
that felt strategic though I really felt
like they didn't need to run that
trailer they certainly need to didn't
need to run it now and it's also
two-and-a-half months out from when
their movie comes out that's crazy they
will literally two fingers in the eyes
it's part of the fun of [ __ ] these
companies now is like that old Marvel DC
feel like Marvel serie take it seriously
and there's still like poke at DC and I
feel like we're not even up and running
yet would you [ __ ] give us a break
not going all in now oh my god I'm
telling you man like Deadpool made it
hard for Batman V Superman because
you're like here's something completely
different and even though Batman V
Superman is like you've never seen these
two [ __ ] before and stuff it doesn't
seem like you know right like we're
reinventing the wheel here and like
Deadpool also seemed to be a commentary
on how dark and ridiculous these movies
have got absolutely a function on a
couple different levels yeah but it was
very much just like a gloss on me you
can actually have fun while doing this
it doesn't have to feel like it's you
know we're sorry
yeah as well as those areas goods it
doesn't have to be yeah so was kind of
and you know blame out him think that
was like Fox going let's [ __ ] with
Warner Bros Fox Fox was terrified of
that movie and then they weren't yeah
then they realize holy [ __ ] we might
happen and it's as much a commentary on
you know Man of Steel and the upcoming
Batman V Superman as it is on like Bryan
Singer's x-men yeah which are very
serious very serious boo you know they
had to be in you know 2000 when you're
launching it but it doesn't have to be
in 2016 when we can just have some fun
I'd be if I was Batman V Superman and
Deadpool happened before me I'd be like
[ __ ] just made my job harder yeah but
that [ __ ] trailer and them going
here's what spider-man's going to look
like and be like in a movie that's
coming two months after this movie is a
real [ __ ] thumb in the eye finger up
the ass you don't have a good way
no yeah really I like more just like I
have you know where bug me
um yeah man I mean look Batman V
Superman gonna do very well but yeah
it's just a real kind of like thank you
bygone like yeah we're gonna show you
we're gonna pull our spider [ __ ] out
right before you go [ __ ] sleep with
who you think is your dream mate like
that's the thing we're all a cop out
every super mint and all sudden [ __ ]
Marvel dangles Little Neck tip as we're
heading down the altar tell me it down
the aisle to the altar and stuff just
makes you stop and think before you
commit those vows suddenly you're like
wait a second hold on what's going on
over there I don't know how many
analogies we can come over but [ __ ] this
trailer was fantastic who's Greg Kot
trailer great [ __ ] positioning in
terms of like let's get that out there
now
you know and it's insulin use experiment
and it's so much about tone like it
baked the movie feels it feels
apocalyptic in a way by the apocalypse
is an emotional one I'm not seeing a
bunch of [ __ ] go down unless it's
directly commentating on
the horror of so much [ __ ] going down
yeah look they show it's the only time
they show us giant buildings going down
this time is when they're like this is
what you do who our fault guys you
sokovia in New York but they also like
gave us like you know at the end of the
Batman V Superman the second trail shoes
with you you know they're like that'll
slam them and that wasn't like you know
what that's the one guy in the world you
don't want equipment yeah you don't quit
you don't want bad jokes you want the
Batman Forever credit card no always
goes room and it's believe me I'm not
saying like I ruined the mood but it's
not at all but that's why a lot of
people reacted the way they did mmm he's
holding a gun what looks like a gun and
he's Megan [ __ ] joke um but this
trailer ends with underoos which number
one is like genius so [ __ ] genius
um doesn't make any sense but it doesn't
matter well apparently they exist in
their world I got I guess so is there do
they even make them anymore well I can't
understand that
not even close alright he's a bit works
for me oh my god I loved it the first
time I watched I was like these and I
couldn't think because they showed me a
web that showed caps hands wet together
Captain America webbing on his wrists
and there was [ __ ] Spider Man holding
cap shield I know to be their [ __ ]
new logo Marvel we could do anything
really it would be like spider-man
wearing Batman's cowl which is mr. hey
guys um I can't see oh my god it was
[ __ ] Glory's so yeah man [ __ ]
Civil War I'm so a dude if that's civil
war if that's Captain America 3 how
[ __ ] insane is infinity war girl I
can't imagine you know what I'm saying
when they pop that trailer up and you're
like oh it's all of this but inch
[ __ ] smash this is a bag I mean that
that's the genius of this universe is
that Kevin Feige has turned
an entire populace into comic book nerds
yeah who are now waiting for the
ultimate contest of Champions which is
basically this movie that will have 70
characters in it oh my god just like
flying around punching each other in the
face what you hear is the table lifting
because I'm just getting so turreted you
know like as I remember when when you
know you're looking at something like
Batman Forever mm you know what
okay how many bad guys I'm the good
we're introducing Robin and then okay we
got to face and Riddler and then these
eight characters is too many characters
you can't tell me a story that has these
many characters who all need origins and
blah blah blah now we're gonna get
everybody yeah but we know all our
stories except for Thanos yeah and there
are those of us who know that knows that
story as well but they're gonna do a
very good job of explaining it yeah and
we might actually finally have a Marvel
villain worthy of like you know more
more than just loki wears a glove
okay Loki or like Tony Stark's evil twin
Jesus um I don't know man it's crazy but
here's what based on that civil war
trailer now I'm aching for an infinity
war trailer because think of the shot
selection involved you know what I'm
saying like these cats that Marvel don't
cut a bad trailer think of the [ __ ]
Wow moments that they are plotting right
now Kim Boggy going like we're gonna
need this because you got to finish
these shots way to [ __ ] out
by the time Civil War happens you know
we're probably gonna get an infinity war
trailer right or something I think
you'll get black panther thanks I think
you get infinity war just shooting it
right now I think no I don't think so
but I shouldn't fit anymore it doesn't
yeah they just [ __ ] started it yeah
maybe right
so then Oh or Doctor Strange that's
probably well yeah we're told to get
Doctor Strange will totally we might get
a sneaky black panther but you know
their plot in that trailer now dude and
he's sitting there gone okay we're
definitely gonna get one you got to
finish these shots visually way far out
he's like we're definitely gonna want
the Thanos [ __ ] pulling Tony out of
the armor shot like like the way you
would [ __ ] take a [ __ ] chicken and
debone it or so
um you put that shot in a trailer
[ __ ] everybody's like I'm [ __ ]
they de Beaune Iron Man like a chicken
um just think of that do because
somebody sat there probably Kevin Feige
was just like okay we're definitely
going to want ant-man on an arrow
blasting through Tony's fingers we're
definitely gonna want you know [ __ ]
uh black black panther taking Winter
Soldier off do you see him hop over that
[ __ ] car
yep with the legs and just watch the
bike ah [ __ ] kids dude and just
there's a very emotional shot of what's
the actor is playing oh um chadwick
boseman like after an explosion what
looked like a un or some [ __ ] in a suit
yes
knit so yeah his hero origin core not
hero urgent but kind of like a man not
like the reason why he's [ __ ] there
trying to get the Winter Soldier now
we're getting more the story in the
trailer - so the black panther he don't
like the Winter Soldier either because
obviously did something bad and what
kind of yeah um oh no it's like it
[ __ ] this is why I'll pay and overpay
for those movies because you get like
this about anything in life you know
what I'm saying
like you got the shoulder you get like
this a bunch of kids I wasn't so my kids
show last night Jim musicals lovely but
I could talk about this bar from now
until the day I die I don't think I'll
ever talk about a joke okay lovely show
she did very well it did great but like
come on did you see black panther take
that guy off the motorcycle we can do
[ __ ] ours owner shot roadie out of
this guy all of it dude is just so right
like they're just tuned to my
vibrational frequency it's perfection
um alright so there's that trailer did
that happen Oh win scene then there was
another trailer that dropped which I
talked about Hollywood babble-on we
should talk about here Ghostbusters
trailer yeah dropped and boarded a drop
and has shown up as one of the only any
things on YouTube that has more dislikes
than likes like even that girl who sang
it's Friday
I think she had more likes than dislike
yeah but this Ghostbusters trailer the
first one they put up was last I looked
it was a hundred and fifty thousand
likes
three hundred thousand or more dislikes
like it was crazy MA a lot of people
reacted poorly to it and the reason why
I think is because you got a [ __ ]
tall bar we all know what Ghostbusters
is and the trailer that first trailer
they went with was not good it's not
strong now as I've gone to great lengths
to explain and make sure that everybody
[ __ ] understands like I have nothing
but hope for this movie because in fact
beyond hope
there is no way that Paul Feig failure
and Melissa McCarthy and Kristen Wiig
and Leslie Jones and cake and mckinnon
that there's r5 bonafide funny people
legit funny people there's no way that
they don't make a funny movie I don't
give a [ __ ] and we've already seen a
little bit evidence of it if there's a
second trailer in international tree
international trailer which is actually
funnier and cut better like you know
it's a lot of the same material but the
presentation is all [ __ ] difference
almost as if they were like well let's
not do that if that was horrible oh my
god I don't want that [ __ ] reaction
and they put in a little more Thor with
systems with Chris Hemsworth but it's
you know it's a better trailer I don't
know to tell you that trailers better
tell if they had opened with that
trailer there might still be some
grousing about like where's all the
jokes and [ __ ] but there were more jokes
in that European trailers yeah in a
national trailer I think that there's
that there's those two different prongs
of it there's it wasn't a good trailer
hmm and this was not the first way to
come out and make your case for your
movie but they're also an entire swath
of people predisposed to hate this movie
they were they were on the edge of their
seats right like they just you know they
they're butthurt about you know the you
took my Ghostbusters away and change
them goodies and you did things to it
yeah and they were already poised like
even if you turned out the [ __ ] best
piece of marketing even if you turn out
a piece of marketing on the level of
[ __ ] the civil war trailer or the
insanely artful Suicide Squad but
scalers if you lead with that still
you'd have some grousing yeah there
would still be a decent you know
fraction of the population go for the
water [ __ ] I'll see it'll show maybe
on video or whatever [ __ ] that SOB said
she exactly [ __ ] prison
they'd be damned they would look at that
condemn you to [ __ ] red box but you
know they're gonna come see you in
theatres man nobody who hates something
that much can wait till rent I know so I
got a no today I gotta know how much I
hate you this is key guys good of a
meeting that if they had if they had
done everything correctly that's you
know best-case naira they've stepped out
with the not the strongest foot to put
forward and it just made every one of
those [ __ ] animals jump like every
hair is a what I know it it with my
childhood got nothing to do with gender
look I don't care make every one of
those people in that first trailer a man
and cells and Joe it's the better
bedroom and it's it you know somebody
pointed out I was saying that feels like
a trailer put together without having
had a test screening hmm like maybe it
was put together in the dark so to speak
without having knowing what audiences
will find funny somebody else online
pointed out like maybe those are the
only shots they had done the effect
shots uh but I would you know I pull
Kevin Feige and plan that [ __ ] months
out and be like these are the shots you
need done because this is the trailer
the matter what tone you put on it we
need these shots yeah you only get one
first trailer yeah I'll get one first
first impression yes
theirs was difficult so they've got it
you know
look I'm they got my money and [ __ ]
going regardless and a lot of people are
gonna go regardless yeah but you know
for those haters that did not help the
cause much at all but again I submit to
you that's not the movie there's no way
there's no [ __ ] way those five people
don't make something [ __ ] enjoyable
somebody pointed out in line like the
spy trailer was not good
we're not as good or what it's true I
remember watching the spot trailer and
bailing on here but when I saw that
movie I was like [ __ ] way funnier and
then goddamn trailer so I think this is
the case with this and I think the
evidence is
strong for the movie based or stronger
based on that international trailer yeah
you know they there's some jokes there's
a story there and some some original
[ __ ] that you haven't seen before and
you know [ __ ] Leslie Jones doing stage
dive and being like I don't care if it's
a woman thing or a black dick
that's funny so yeah it's unfortunate
that that's how they and did you notice
the International trailer makes a change
at the top hmm so the American trailer
says for site or for scientists save the
world or something like that right this
one says for friends 30 years ago for
friends save the world
huh in that in that interesting
I guess science and friendship can't
live never yeah you can't be friends of
the science friends somebody should tell
Tony Stark and Peter Parker you can't be
science friends proving thus further
that [ __ ] mr. wizard hated all those
children it's like I'm a man of science
I can't be friends with a child Bill Nye
the Science get hate you okay what you
do is you light that on fire and I go in
another room while you explode [ __ ] off
well I think again reality science in
children fantasies all you want to do is
play science a play some Zack science
Neil deGrasse Mike Tyson's punching
children people like him though they did
I see and he seems to like people you
know he's wondering tell Gary he's the
one that breaks the mold he's like on
the one side she loves about everybody a
giant heart I know how the heart works
and the open search inside watches I do
the sexual side more than you okay so we
did that trailer we did that trailer
we're minutes away from Batman V
Superman yeah you cannot avoid marketing
is everywhere all the billboards are
here I mean this man I wonder if that's
the world over if that's just Los
Angeles I think it's kind of everywhere
is it
the [ __ ] Jam billboards up your
[ __ ] ass because everyone lives here
and they want to drive past their
billboard yeah if it is less for the
people yeah for the people who make the
movie pretty much how do you go up on
the in the sky Los Angeles let it
oh it's everywhere man oh that was
posters of him about to punch him in the
face and the cereal boxes rolling in
stores and you seen anything you heard
anything uh I've spoken a couple people
who've seen it how they see it the early
early journalists screenings like
Longley presses I have to do that for
long night and did the response is mixed
really yeah it's mixed mixed in now the
people that are the not positive side
mm-hmm are they comic book people uh yes
really yeah hmm yeah I'm seeing it on
Thursday are you this [ __ ] Thursday
this Thursday are you gonna be [ __ ]
damn I'm gonna be making the DC seen it
coming Lions like you can watch it
that's the only thing that I'll make up
for like not you know seeing it Batman
early is like well I'm making the flash
I can't really force consolation prizes
go um but yeah I guess I'm gonna [ __ ]
see it with you know anyone else's
labels and then we'll talk about in
Detroit yes that's right man we got our
first [ __ ] live show coming up folks
in Detroit what weekend is it the open
31st so silly K is the weekend after the
opening weekend so the dust will have
settled we Thursday know at the 31st
it'll be its first we'll be out of town
so we could be honest yeah anybody here
yeah oh my God we're in Detroit and we
can choose not to put the episode up
alright but who actually talked um I
don't know I'm [ __ ] I'm still down
dude yeah gonna do it right he looks
good and I'm all you know I'm all for
[ __ ] spumoni don't have to be one
flavor like I love the Deadpool flavor
I'm okay for [ __ ] more
straightforward beat him up her flavor
that Batman V Superman seems to be hand
in this and also come on dude [ __ ]
prick they're gonna launch a universe in
one movie just pull
let's go just all in your face and
whether you like it or not we're off and
running and stuff so you know I'm
[ __ ] I can't wait it's such a good
time to be [ __ ] a fan of this [ __ ]
because in this like sense
Deadpool's February 14th I'm February
14th one month in a week one month and
ten [ __ ] days eleven days later
Batman V Superman two months after that
Civil War two months after that Suicide
Squad two months you know what I'm
saying yeah do you sense a pattern here
and don't forget [ __ ] because you're
seeing clips and trailers all over
online daredevil is about to happen
mm-hmm which we all know [ __ ] nothing
real weekend yeah they're dropping a
little early I think the 23rd once again
a real like [ __ ] oh oh were you
releasing a movie I'm sorry I'm sorry
let me just pull my other giant dick it
did you want a new cycle to yourself cuz
I don't think he's gonna get
unbelievable
it's not enough to win they just got to
defeat everybody else scorched earth Wow
I respect that no I'm dead what his
family dead okay I was a prisoner doing
a total [ __ ] Al Capone on a Monday Oh
God it's nuts
but it's good for us dude all this
competition is great for an audience cuz
it just means each one of them you ain't
getting you'll never get you know
everyone's our Joel Schumacher bottle
Yuliya never get one of the movies again
let's somebody do it intentionally to be
like remember this yeah as an ironic Joe
we will never be on another quest for
peace no dude its quest for money now
man quest for eyeballs ear balls and
[ __ ] attention building franchises
and world building so my god these
movies are only getting better and
better at least the trailers are and
[ __ ] when you see the movies you're
like [ __ ] they did it
I know people keep on you know ragging
me a little bit on logic man how come
you don't want to love Batman V
Superman's like you're always down Isaac
I want these movies to be great yeah I
want them all to be amazed look I
already love Batman V Superman I don't
care I don't care how bad they [ __ ] it
up if they [ __ ] it up I love that movie
because that's the beginning of DC you
right there like now we're seeing pieces
go to God dude I've always want to see
Batman Superman together in a movie of
course of course and now we're going to
see that but more importantly
they're going to be like here's your
Wonder Woman here's your [ __ ] cyborg
here's your you know I'm too keen on the
idea of a new flash but because they got
perfectly [ __ ] fantastically I'm
telling you man they should really
reconsider and just be like DC movie
universe and TV university should
marbleize it yeah they've already done
the [ __ ] hard work man of like usual
here's your origin put that [ __ ] in ah
yeah like Marvel is taught an audience
to be okay with it yes the heavy lifting
of converting an audience into the
continuity mindset is done yeah so just
you know you don't need to rebuild this
wheel no just [ __ ] let them run into
it yeah I know a thing or two about a
thing or two and I can't chair but
Supergirl as we all know upcoming
episode is going to meet the flash yeah
and who is the fastest man alive I think
is the versus personal life sorry uh yes
there's an image of them like race
there's I imagine there's a race in
vogue yes the better be otherwise but it
is I know how it happens I know how it
how it happens on flash as well like
there's a bit of connection it's all
very clever and wonderful but I also
heard some stuff about Supergirl got
picked up yet so and so did flash and
they're all this all the CW sleep
nothing Berlanti has his finger on got
cancelled that's true oh my god could
you imagine and we went to Linda on that
island that he bought buying another
island to celebrate video we want to
duplex this [ __ ] out oh my god I'm
getting over like don't you just quit
that day cuz you're like I'll never have
a better news cycle than this yeah and
all of my shows on different networks
got picked up um I would have to get
[ __ ] Kealing like a bus full of hookers
they go wrong Oh Greg said ow dammit
because all the hookers all the hookers
yeah unless there was a good reason was
there good reason good let's give him
the benefit of doubt everybody possibly
good reason good II have
murder where they teaching kids science
again yeah science hookers right never
about love only for money um yeah so
they got picked up so super girls
happening again next season and I
there's there's some cool [ __ ] in the
hopper a cool multiverse ship in the
harbor yeah I was like uh uh they just
like they're real secretive up there
with good reason you have to be um but
like I got some dough I'd pry it out of
[ __ ] cold dead fingers and stuff but
I got some dope that I was like oh dude
you know what I was here I'm calling it
yeah you know what else is gonna be
[ __ ] astounding you know Burrell
auntie's doing Riverdale yes [ __ ] a
dude they're shooting it right now I'm
there I've seen a lot of the elements at
work and stuff and I've been talking to
folks who work on it flash as well that
shows [ __ ] I want that now I want to
see that show really yeah like and it
was kind of on my radar because they
talked we talked about on Babylon and it
they said Bill Anderson I was like I
botched that [ __ ] dude do anything
including my wife he's so good at that
yeah so you know I was like right on
like a Archie show that'll be
interesting and the take on it is
[ __ ] like it's not like hey we're all
Archie it's not everything as Archie
it's it's very Twin Peaks hmm and we're
it's the town is a functioning character
it's [ __ ] good dude like where you're
like holy [ __ ] um I'm looking forward to
it
like right away because all the elements
let you see the design books and the
[ __ ] and the and I saw Archie getting
picked up yeah had to be Archie had
unnaturally orange hair look like a
movie star with weird orange eyes I
guess God does magic
they're shooting another show up there
right now which is that DC Universe
office-type Joan Carles powerless yeah I
always want to say damage control but
that's the Marvel which they're also
doing which they're also doing but not
shooting
I don't think so I ran into Vanessa
Hudgens she's up there shooting that and
our boys in it it was on her show
[ __ ] two dicks oh the King Allen the
king of two dicks she said she goes do
you know Alan Tudor I said gnome I know
both of his dick she said ah he's very
funny and she said the guy from
community is honoring Joel McHale no
Danny Pudi yes she said he's very funny
as well yeah I went into Allen at the
Long Beach Comic Expo mmm I was down
there for a panel it's like oh hey Allen
two dicks I didn't say it the man of to
do this man up to the extent of one
world with two dicks the and also a
shout-out to your boy dude Zak's tents
yes is the writer of my episode of flash
um and boy do you [ __ ] crush it like
the RAI once again the writers king in
this medium and stuff and like he gave
me a beautiful [ __ ] gift whether he
knew he was giving me that gift or not
beautiful [ __ ] gift this episode I
couldn't ask for a better episode for me
to direct their elements at play here
that are like Oh looking perfect for me
but you have to stop crying we're
picking it up on mics dude I don't know
how I'm gonna have to tie a pillow to my
[ __ ] face get through some of these
seams but so much so that like the you
could tell the cast did get to the leg
we got something here you know and it's
in really strong stuff Zak is a friend
of marks he's also he's a movie guy he's
like it's a writer when Mark was telling
me he's like I think a friend of mine is
writing your script I was like huh all
right well [ __ ] you know I guess you
get who he can get away mark is it like
even wrote one of the movies like who's
that guy what's he ever done before is
it will he wrote Thor an x-men first is
the
yeah man they got a legit [ __ ] scream
ready to write this [ __ ] episode of
the flash I guess like they write a lot
in house but then there's a couple a
year that they assign out yea they save
like for freelancers and they got Zach
to do and [ __ ] it he crush it it's a
wonderful [ __ ] script
um that's that I mean thank God could
you imagine I got up there and I was
just like well number one there's never
been a bad episode so I don't think
unless this was the first one I got
there and they look URI Gilbert
it's a fake it just says the fake flash
that mean I felt like nothing just shoot
it cuz I we figured they're gonna watch
it because Kevin Smith is directing it
we don't need to make it good really
have just been Punk'd I don't like the
real episode is being shot across town
he's such a clearly not the sets do did
you notice
but like you're just too polite to say
anything good you love the shows joke's
on you but there's masking tape but
everything is set and the flash is Sue's
is Green Lantern shoot you didn't even
say anything Rockridge um so it is uh
yeah it's a great [ __ ] not it's a
nice great script and he's a witty job
and the the caskets to do some cool
stuff and there's some cool [ __ ] like
deep cuts continuity stuff we were able
to weave into the episode as well by way
of like locations and stuff like that um
is it you know it's a group effort when
you put together one of these things
that's though it's different from the
world I'm used to operate and you yes
it's always a group effort to make a
film but there's you know you don't look
at toss can go like boy the crew must
have come up with some of this you know
that's that's one vision of one idiot
this is like the visions of many
talented crafts people coming together
tell the story not your story were a
story but the story right pretty
impressive um all right so wait we
talked about that we talked about that
um was there any other big news that we
hit mm-hmm don't think so
so weirdly like other than those things
yeah like we [ __ ] even use a Marvel
own the [ __ ] week pretty much with
that [ __ ] trailer job
we're almost there kids Batman is about
to be the [ __ ] out of Superman and we're
gonna see every [ __ ] frame of it
every name of it man there's that one
movie theater is selling up like a bat
pass like a gold card that you could buy
and you can see the movie at once a day
every day if you want okay that's like a
hundred or two hundred dollars like it's
a pretty steep amount where I'm like
knowing full well that like nobody's
gonna do that okay give us $200 and
you'll see if five times and I somebody
had to have done it dude somebody
[ __ ] bought it I mean they'll buy
they might not go every day and day so
that means the moment those anyone buys
that card doesn't go one day these cats
are we win yeah they look like we're in
the red or black what is it we're gonna
win the [ __ ] good thing yeah we got
money always been on black always this I
would it is red is bad and black is
you're in the black your company's good
yes and you're in the rise of the
deficit and always bet on black is what
Wesley Snipes taught us the win who is
the man Wesley Snipes remember there is
a time when they talked about Wesley
Snipes was gonna be the black panther
yeah like a long time ago yeah yeah for
sure we've lived long enough that like
fantasy alike because there was no
[ __ ] like it was something like one
day maybe it was probably a wizard
[ __ ] you know imagine it and cast and
totally but we live in a world where
there is not only gonna be like
somebody's actually playing the Black
Panther he we're seeing him in a movie
ready we've watched him in action it's
insane it's not stood [ __ ] not
stacked deck over there dude seriously
like if even if you're like [ __ ]
Spider Man damn Brandi black panther
yeah like brand-new character for this
movie you know like the dead man also
kind of new character if you rent see
that movie room if you did putting them
in the context and finally they get
[ __ ] Hawkeye something to do shoot and
manage [ __ ]
launching platform for your other real
hero I keep trying to do [ __ ] with them
first movies a zombie oh look an
Avengers sequel he's you know family man
funny guy but now they're like look you
just be you
you is the [ __ ] setup man your Dean
Martin - this [ __ ] Jerry Lewis
you are Arsenio Hall okay you become
Marvel yeah like at some point Marvel
will finally decide to feel good and for
real kill somebody and know that
somebody's gonna oh my god do you know
he better be the first to go in that New
Avengers movie Oh in Infinity Ward
cuz come on dude they're all going to
space he's got no place but what am i
[ __ ] doin spinning even said in the
last movie the city is flying and I'm
fighting with a bonus big sense um yeah
man [ __ ] I think you may have called
it - hmm
he may be could you imagine now they're
gonna want him in Avengers I was gonna
say maybe he's the [ __ ] backdoor kill
of Civil War everyone thinks it's like
roadie right but maybe it's like finally
summarize is up but we don't need head
[ __ ] at all for fightin let's
kill this guy yeah we already got an
army like they're good Widow is our
norming we're not gonna kill see they
couldn't do that dude there's no N or if
they let a hero kill one of their heroes
if they let one of their heroes die ever
but you're right the process of
elimination dictates that they got a
[ __ ] cannon fodder is Hawkeye pretty
much so the red shirt the monthly
photography process sooner or later he's
gotta be sacrifices Spock and bones and
incident jenkin he's got to look at them
and know that he's Sam Rockwell another
last name um if they wind up doing that
though it would probably have to be at
the hands of Thanos or so yeah which
would be like the most ridiculously
overmatch it could be at the hands of a
mugger at a7 that's not even have to
wait for Thanos he's courting death in
the far reaches of the end of the
universe we could drive by what happened
to Barton I think he was going for a
zagnut and
a guy shot him like who was it was a
Dormammu
no it was like it was a guy it was dude
is honestly is why kid he's 19 came into
the gun [ __ ] nuts just took him out
no no like that's how Hawkeye died on
the bar fall of the hero the opening
five minutes in the [ __ ] infinity war
can I just do it so they're all sad
about the death of Barton and then all
of a sudden a some shits on space and
they buckets drop trou go right up sorry
I don't the wife and kids are okay do it
for pardon and then I'll head back to
the farm and we go as never gonna know
they like that guy man I guarantee you
they're not gonna kill [ __ ] all kinds
you want why not dammit
I bet you a little sack well I mean
they'll find a way to kill Tony Stark
before everybody go like this
[ __ ] cheap it's I dude that's
why like you can't afford Robert Danny
Boy the day that Robert Jenner jr. comes
in gone like I want a hundred million
play Iron Man and he can't because these
movies meant billions so if one guy's
like look let's be honest like you can't
do it without me I'd like a hundred
million dollars the big woo but they'll
be like they get rain and now if Hawkeye
walks in and it's like you know at
$100,000 you're dead to me
okay sorry and the audience I want to
get the crowd services in front of my
trailer
in their ladyhawk out character uh yeah
and the books well who is she um sister
for girlfriend I think I've no relation
whatsoever relation whatsoever just
takes this [ __ ] costume yeah well I
think they're like buddies they team up
after a while there you go man yeah swap
it now for [ __ ] know it makes Hawkeye
interesting being a woman yeah
if you change that character to lady
Hawkeye everybody wins
everyone's like oh my god this is great
it's like watching arrow with all those
girls that shoot there now there's two
ladies number flick universe everyone
shoot arrows on that arrow show dude
they really do
I've seen a clip or two you know the
episodes i watch one
i watch flash that crosses over and
you're speedy and there's arsenal and
then there's greener Thea
yeah there's everybody's sooner or later
would be an ex Berlin they've got to do
the like Milan they must have done a
Mexican standoff with just bows and
arrows around like every third episode
should we shoot no we're not you okay
that's the amazing thing dude like why
it's amazing flash works as well as it
works is they don't even have the
gimmick of like we've all got weapons
that are kind of cool to look at even
though they don't really make much sense
like I mean they make sense in a world
where there is no gun in the world
you're violating this era thing is a
little [ __ ] dated but flash that
could at least work cuz it's like you
know we like seeing weapons and sting
[ __ ] flashes you you not even supposed
to see anything because supposed to runs
a bug and fast and that's is one thing
but man every week they find a way to
make speed work for this guy I am sure
somewhere whether you've seen it with I
don't have anybody seen he's not on that
show but there is a whiteboard somewhere
of this list of [ __ ] you can do with
running fat it's gotta be and
everybody's welcome to add an idea yeah
that's your job buddy your job young
intern is to sit the corner just think
of things you could do with speed if
happens to you you wouldn't think of
[ __ ] like oh my god I [ __ ] dropped my
pizza but if I was flashing upon it you
know that's an episode of Matt's Barry
the waiter you feel like that's a finale
right there what I always loved and it
even it is exists in my episode as well
as there's always like a pseudoscience
kind of like what's he doing he's and
then a paragraph about right what he's
exactly doing with his speed and I would
have felt cheated if I didn't have that
and I have it in my episode excellent I
saw it and instantly I was like oh thank
god it's an official flash episode
because you have to explain this for
some people yeah the Star Trek writers
yeah Ronald Moore who was a writer on
next generation in deep space 9 and then
went on a battle start but used to talk
about writing episodes of Star Trek
where there would just be passages where
all he would write was and so Geordi
text the tech into the text or the tech
does what the techniques to do and
somebody else would figure it out
just figure out what to say just like
we're reversing the quantum polarity on
the inversion field so that we can you
know I Burdine the magna thrusters and
then go so he just essentially put plays
yes biotech into the text or the tech
does with the tech needs to do let's
Jenny we just copy and paste that into
script that's like until when you got
two Battlestars like we are never doing
technobabble we were never taking the
tech it is just this does what it does
this is a Cylon they've got this if it's
doing a thing we're explaining the thing
right but it's not just words to say
he's walking on water
how's he walking on water okay our
particle let me explain that to you and
a couple's that yes if he hit 652 miles
an hour he can run up the side of a
building without falling there I love
that [ __ ] all right
oh my god I love you it I love when I do
that I love when someone realizes what's
Berens usually Cisco yeah realizes
what's Barry what Barry is doing
somebody will be like what is he doing
and Cisco be like he's using his speed
to when he fills it in Captain
exposition but in a really entertaining
way and I love that [ __ ] I'm like that's
the information cuz I'm the idiot who
watches that show goes like what
happened usually somebody has to explain
it thankfully on that show so there's
Cisco to explain it um that's it it's
all we got news time for my merch man
emergency watch vinyl if you hadn't I've
not seen it's good is it enjoyable has
nothing to do with our world in terms of
geekdom and stuff like that celebrities
raw 70s kind of come to life again
early 70s but it's been real enjoyable
yeah alright I've kind of dug it but
more net I mean
clear your schedule because daredevil is
about to happen I know and that's what
is lis 10 hours I think you're ready to
give up a day your life oh my god what a
great month this is
daredevil Batman V Superman then we're
gonna have a special daredevil guest on
the on the video pocket sorry you're
going to have well you're gonna be in
Vancouver and so you don't get to play
or about Lexi Alexander oh the
directress directed the director war
zone what the [ __ ] best punisher
movie ever made yeah yeah she's a
[ __ ] shooter man yeah and she's
directed Supergirl
yeah yeah and I've seen her name on
other thing was wait so she directed did
she direct some Daryl she did but she's
the person previous to this who had put
daredevil on screen so she's going to
win with wisdom Oh put Punisher on
screen yes yes is yes terrible um yeah
yeah partnership ID she handled the
punishment yeah so she's in really well
and you not dude was probably I for my
my life be what [ __ ] you it's Tom Jane
that dude looked like the Punisher yes
and played like the Punisher hmm like a
tank yeah oh my god and I loved him on
Rome that actor but Bernthal dude
[ __ ] can't protect Rick he see me I
think he may define it dude
yeah with the oddly enough to shaved
hair on the side like really [ __ ]
does a lot yeah that's a milot behind
tight just yeah with the fade um it's
your war yeah oh [ __ ] I can't wait to
he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of Punisher
yeah it's gonna be good it's gonna be
good yeah and protect Rick can take the
cheating man what bad day with being me
just throw that in just watching The
Walking Dead is wrong now it's good yeah
a very great things something's about to
happen
yeah it's always better the other dude
gonna walk they uh they did a [ __ ]
episode this week that was pretty like
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] where you know
normally they're fighting the dead but
they were this wasn't even fighting the
living I mean spoilers so if you haven't
watched it they like go in and kill
[ __ ] in their sleep was very
disturbed by that but it was weird I
felt real like that's it that that may
be the thing that like unsettled me most
on that show around this time because
they showed them like you know these
people are just sleeping in bed and
month of holding [ __ ] like Glenn's
got a knife over the dudes [ __ ] face
and and then they just cut up to Glenn
and you know just you just hear and you
know they just stabbed this [ __ ]
through the eye in asleep and he's dead
the Etzel [ __ ] up and he was a living
person he wasn't a a [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] didn't do anything to them
wasn't even like the killed Maggie like
or something like that they [ __ ] they
just attacked them it was [ __ ] we
ought very not like [ __ ]
a show or something like that but I was
like oh my god that's the most of all
the horrible things I've seen on that
show like I'll never sleep well again
knowing that somebody could just stab me
there's like an eye and brain and kill
me my sleeve thanks Glenn
no my god dude it's like you go to sleep
gone I got some [ __ ] to do tomorrow and
stuff like that then you don't wake up
cuz somebody stabbed you to death in
your sleep I didn't think about their
canteens now I'm looking at my wife all
weird yeah are you doing yeah a girl
asleep first you should sleep in a
separate room like it really made me
like it made me question like what is
this hole we sleep with others things
[ __ ] unsafe we all need a panic room
what if you go Glenn in the middle of
the night [ __ ] want to stab you today
it's come to the point now where I wish
for like some kind of ailment to lay me
up in a hospital bed for like three or
four weeks just to watch TV catch up on
just to watch all the [ __ ] that I missed
you need an assassination attempt dude
ooh like Ronald Reagan in the 80s and
shits and go to the hospital and me just
like convalesce while watching she looks
like how about a tapeworm you guys like
I need to drop some weight need to catch
a bunch of TVs and I don't want to [ __ ]
with any vitals no and just like mark
can't [ __ ] watch TV Mark's got a new
job Abbi job sign let's close out the
show with that well number one we're
coming to Detroit go buy tickets at sea
smart calm watch me and Mark do [ __ ]
this lie yes with you guys and stuff
we'll figure out a format on the way
like hey Detroit what do you guys want
you know what you guys gonna talk about
but uh we'll probably bring people on
the [ __ ] shadow dude because we can
open it up to Q&A not Q&A about like us
but like let's talk about everyone you
know yeah they all got a thing yeah
we're like let's lean toward that and
your favorite superhero
don't miss your show is are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me I'm paying 40 Foxx for [ __ ]
who's your favorite superhero yeah yeah
that's the world we live in man what do
you think you idiot [ __ ] glorious
check up um speaking of check off mark a
huge classy job tell them but I had a
classy John man I'm working for the LA
Times I'm Robbie Robertson that's all I
can think you're just happy to make a
gig Kinetico goon
oh dammit JJ you literally could have
went Perry White now I could have but
you went deep cut away remember that's
an honor of [ __ ] a dick Oh looking
spider-man we saw in the trailer this
week um tell them what that means yeah
I'm working on a film editor for the LA
Times now for those of us that live out
here of course like that's like LA Times
and paper record but to be fair
LA Times one of the biggest papers on
the planet you New York Times you got
your Washington Post you got your what
well Chicago is her get your beer immune
or some time here and LA Times legit San
Francisco Chronicle like there's five of
them left and they're smart works of one
part of my plan you say mallanna walks
between we're losing the door on the
chairs bar when I leave what what is
that job entail dad job entails seeing a
lot of moves that means you will see
[ __ ] but Oh
I'm sitting there gone I thought I was
like was he seeing it early for LA Times
[ __ ] Burt oh my god dude you're gonna
see everything early I'm hoping so
really that's all I'm gonna for what
[ __ ] yeah Wow that's [ __ ] sweet yeah
but it's it's kind of like there's a
bunch it's like five or six really smart
writers there mmm and it's just like
helping them tell their stories the best
way they can help it and set the tone
helping to set a bit of an agenda not
that I have one but and it's not even
what is the geek thing about hero
complex he's not hero complex you're the
editor of the film section yeah that's
all things movies all the time it's huge
I mean hero complex will overlap given
that we are in the world we're in where
every two weeks there's some giant
[ __ ] shiny geek thing but the
no-brainer job it would have been hero
complex like you guys were [ __ ] you
do well but they were like well you do
that in podcast as a grownup you will
talk about everything you will talk
about foreign movies and real movies are
real people doing real things but
spider-man you guys he's got eyes that
move I was literally in a meeting like
so what's coming up for the next week
I'm like next week
[ __ ] spider-man and the week after
spider-man my man and then Punisher no
punishes TV you can't
yeah an electric suit and a lecture yeah
we should mention would they've added
another man who walks between the worlds
man whoohoo um what's his name JK
Simmons yeah was just cast this week as
kin this DC universes Commissioner
Gordon
so JK Simmons as we all know is over at
Sony the og technically not yeah the og
JJ jonah Jameson in the world of the
movie version of spider-man not
technically Marvel you which means
they'll have to get a new J Joe no
Jameson yeah yeah but that's okay um was
he Jade jonah Jameson in the nightma
second one in the mock web they didn't
even have one remember right like you
saw his name but he was too big to
replace they couldn't replace JK you
can't replace Vernon Schillinger
Dillinger he will always be fresh
chicken [ __ ] to me that's all men arrest
if you haven't seen odds right and you
really really love JK Simmons watch oz
and watch that love for chicky
equipments evaporate and turn it to fear
it's also kind of like the role that he
won the Oscar for in what was that
moving whiplash whiplash it's a less
rapey version ah it's a general world
view just like 20% less exact but you
just won't get a diggity right right
it's like how do I set more Nazi he
slaps you percent and now he's
Commissioner Gordon that's a good good
call he's really good yeah yeah it sees
a really cool actor it always has been
and he'll like he'll find a way you know
Gary Oldman we got to see the
relationship with Batman grow this is a
Batman already established so he's got
to play his Commissioner Gordon as I
I know that Bruce Wayne is Batman and
has been Batman for years mobile ba yeah
and deal with a guy in a suit and make
that plausible yeah like we don't have
to deal with the yet the the I put a I
put my jacket around a 11-year old boy
it's yeah we've been doing this for 50
years now that's right I did the [ __ ]
11 or old boy years again
like that but I did and that's why they
kiss JK Simmons folks if that's how we
do it here in the fat caveman I guess
that's all the news that's fit to print
this oh we go let's send them home and
after a little [ __ ] hear candy yeah
it's been a while it's been a while
thanks for hanging out was here in the
fat caveman come back next week we'll
talk some more [ __ ]
I've been Kevin Smith mark barnard and
you catch us here every week same fad
time same fat Channel so I guess I come
and get to thing you get is there
a man's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder